[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro deux
peuples le premier de la rentrée avec
une formule mikko vide et si je peux
dire puisque je suis en plateau avec
anne père brio bonjour vous êtes
conseiller régional de la région ile de
france proche de valérie pécresse au
plateau également mustapha larbaoui
bonjour bonjour à patrice bon vous êtes
le président et fondateur de pharma
citoyens correct et vous êtes conseiller
municipal d'opposition à trappes vous
dire ça comme ça on peut le dire mais
faudrait déjà que je me fasse aussi pour
vous et puis nous sommes en duplex avec
charlène bezina bonjour vous êtes maître
de conférences à l'université de roi
jean michel2 chaussaire bonjour alors
vous êtes vous êtes sociologue vous êtes
dedans society que vous ne vous êtes
chercheur associé au centre d'études et
de recherches sur les emplois et les
prophètes une génération
rens et vous êtes aussi certes chercheur
associé au centre de recherches
sociologiques sur le droit et les
institutions pénales d'une université de
versailles saint quentin et puis on
parlera un petit peu parce que vous avez
un parcours formidable
vous êtes un chercheur et un
universitaire mais pendant 30 ans 35 ans
vous avez été sur le terrain puisque
vous avez été policier 1
donc comme on va beaucoup parler de la
violence vous nous donnerez votre
expertise à la fois chercheur est à la
fois d'homme de terrain
et puis jean baptiste duclair bonjour
vous êtes vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'université de versailles
saint quentin
voilà alors on va peut-être commencer
par ce qui s'est passé de ce matin du 4
septembre fiscaux fêter les cent
soixante dix ans dit on de la république
aurait l'idée c'est de la troisième
république qu'est ce qu'il y avait eu 2
avant un peu plus courte en effet mais
enfin c'est vrai que ça fait cent
soixante dix ans si on met à part la
parenthèse de vie si que nous sommes
sous le sous le régime de la république
on a le projet prévoit la pression comme
ça que au fond c'est u c'est un régime
qui va perdurer qui va qui va continuer
d'exister qui n'aura pas de fin et on
al'impression justement contraire
aujourd'hui que c'est un régime qui est
en difficulté et qui peut être menacée
et d'ailleurs le discours d' emmanuel
macron ce matin au panthéon a été un
discours assez offensif
est-ce que vous pensez que la république
est menacée qui veut tu veux répondre
chacun peut être c'est vrai qu'on
constate ces dernières années une forme
de recrudescence des particularismes de
l'identité régionale de l'identité
religieuse et on a tendance à penser que
c'est l'universalisme républicain
finalement qui est mise à mal par ces
dernières revendications
je crois qu'on vit aussi une triste
année pour la république par rapport à
ses grands débats identitaires qui font
que la liberté d'expression elle même et
dans un carcan qui est celui de de ne
pas oser prononcer certains mots sous
peine d'être considéré comme dans un
discours raciale dans un discours
haineux dans un discours sexistes et
c'est donc il ya peut-être trop de
censure dans la liberté d'expression
quel fondement de la république qui
aujourd'hui remette un peu en cause ce
pacte républicain mais j'ai confiance
dans la république et je pense
qu'institutionnellement la république en
tout cas elle est en quelque sorte un
peu inévitable parce que je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait d'autres modèle monarchique
ou oligarchie qui puisse vraiment se
prêter à notre système de gouvernement
mais on vit des tristes années peut-être
plus par rapport à la conscience
républicaine et aussi à la
représentation de l'identité qu'on en a
je me sens un peu le regard des
sociologues sur ces sujets charlène on
est plutôt s'est pas véritablement la
démocratie turque l'institution
elle-même
il est mise à mal mais le pape alors
huîtres ensemble qui est morcelée qui
est fractionné pour utiliser des termes
ont été convaincus dans des paris sur
les centres et notamment au niveau de la
violence une forme d'expression qui
relèveraient à mon sens et je pense que
c'est plutôt heureux par la gare avec
effectivement la société qui ne sont
plus les tensions qu'on a pu commettre
franchement économique social perdu
évidemment mais qui sont parce que des
tensions idéologiques et c'est ce qui
vaut aux élus que vous êtes perdriau
justement on parlera tout à leur
bailleur des violences contre les élus
parce qu'elles se multiplient
aujourd'hui mais est-ce que donc voir
quand vous avez mené des élections des
suivis des campagnes électorales
yahia quand même aussi maintenant
peut-être que ça toujours eu une
certaine violence danser dans ses
campagnes
et parfois qui me fait pas qui n'est pas
respectueuse au fond de la démocratie de
la république
oui c'est vrai et je pense que ça va
avec ça va avec une ambiance générale
tout ce qui est représentatif de la
république justement de l'ordre est un
peu mise à mal
ça c'est certain et c'est plus une
ambiance
alors évidemment il ya les faits il ya
l'effet très concrets que dans les
médias font écho et puis après il ya ce
fameux sentiment d'insécurité dont on
reparlera peut-être après voilà qui est
plutôt due à un faisceau de deux
sentiments qui met à mal la république
et les élus républicains bien sûr les
muses de valeur mobile j'irais pas
jusqu'a dire que la république est
menacé dans ses fondements parce que
après tout la chose publique pour donner
le la sollicitation et la signification
du mot la chose publique elle est
toujours prise en main par tous les
démocrates de ce pays n'y par des par
définition le suffrage universel fin
dans toutes les valeurs je crois qu'il
est bon de les rappeler quand même si la
république n'est pas menacée moi j'ai le
sentiment qu'il ya des des éléments sur
la sur les valeurs de celles ci qui sont
parfois attaquer et puis et puis à des
gens qui mettent ce qu'ils veulent dans
ce mot république il ya la république
laïque
il ya des républiques qui sont enclins à
vouloir aller sur des modèles un peu
plus théologien donc tout dépend ce
qu'on veut lui met mais je pense qu'il
est bon de rappeler les fondements d'une
part l'histoire les fondements et les
valeurs de la république par de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité donc il ya des
choses comme ça qui sont remises en
cause et ce qu'on a une vraie liberté
dans cette république est ce qu on a une
vraie égalité dans cette république ce
qu'on a une vraie fraternité donc sur
ses fondements la public surtout démarre
cette semaine a chuté je crois que le
débat le débat est sain j'irais pas
jusqu'a dire qu'elle est menacée
simplement l'histoire a prouvé qu'il
fallait être extrêmement vigilant sur
des changements de régime et
il y en a qui seraient tentés
effectivement d'aller chercher des
déversant un peu noir qu'on a pu
connaître dans la dans l'histoire donc
menacée non je crois qu'il faut être
vigilant et l air et rappelé les
fondements peut-être les expliquer de
façon plus plus facile également des
fois j'ai l'impression qu'on parle
beaucoup de ces choses là je sais pas si
parfois on comprend tout ce qu'on veut
bien nous dire en tout cas mon sentiment
je tourne jean baptiste d'éclat il ya
peut-être encore dit elle est peut-être
m'a menacé mais il ya quand même si on
regarde l'europe ne serait ce que
l'europe une percée des des régimes
autoritaires alors je sais pas si c'est
encore républicains coupables enfin ça
existe avant de répondre à cette
question simplement dire que moi je ne
suis pas d'accord avec le conseiller de
l'anniversaire de la république le mordu
pour ce que vous faites en 2005 fixé la
date de proclamation qui est fait dans
des conditions tout à fait vrai jeu
anarchique si je puis dire par vendetta
de la république mais en fait la vraie
date de naissance de la république ses
1100 5 1 contre 100 jeunes notamment
qu'en 1871 lorsque pour la première fois
on a créé des élections en france a
donné une majorité très large des
monarchistes et la voilà la pré date
d'anniversaire
c'est plutôt 50 ans
[Musique]
parce que aussi d'ailleurs on compare
notre vie actuelle de la soutiennent
donc avec la troisième ont sous la
iiième rappeler où on a eu le scandale
des décorations la pièce du panama
louanges hills va perdre et pu décrire
le réel qui ont pu menacer notre
république
aujourd'hui je crois que dans ces grands
pendant l'année pas menacé mais il est
vrai que si on regarde ailleurs que chez
nous il ya non pas des régimes
autoritaires puisqu'il n'y a pas de
changement quant aux frais de la forme
du régime mais il a dit donc dans un
cadre républicain ou des autorités frise
avec l'ani mourouj parfois sans mal à
dépasser rendu des valeurs alors le
discours des manuels du maquereau au
panthéon est un discours assez offensif
et qui était un discours d'autorité
alors ça répond sans doute à une
exigence aussi actuelle puisque il ya un
mot qui a fait beaucoup parler ces
derniers
ces dernières semaines c'est le boude
dans son engagement lancé vaguement de
la société ça va être le premier thème
de cette émission
[Musique]
oui les violences alors l'ont
sauvagement c'est en un mot qui a été
utilisé par le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin qui est contestée
d'ailleurs par le ministre de la justice
qui devait donner ce mot s'est excité le
sentiment d'insécurité mais c'est vrai
que j'ai eu un certain nombre de faits
divers
un chauffeur de bus qui est mort parce
qu'il avait demandé à des passagers de
mettre un masque une infirmière etc
enfin va pas faire la liste des faits
divers qui se sont succédé au mois de
juillet au mois d'août mais c'est vrai
que il ya eu ce sentiment peut-être que
l'autorité de l'état et l'autorité de
façon générale est en crise et que
l'insécurité augmenté je vais me tourner
vers vous jean michel lecerf est ce que
parce que dans tout ça il est d'abord
pourrait dire il ya des chiffres qui
montrent que ça montre que ça monte pas
mais les cibles sont assez incertain s
qu est-ce qu on connait vraiment des
chiffres sur la beauté ou pas la montée
de la délinquance de la police haïtien
des vacances alessio l'insee les siens
des chicots mais qui sont qui sont
parfois au même niveau et sur certaines
tranches de d2 qui venaient nous sommes
parfois contradictoires on y lit à nos
rêves général malgré tout une petite de
hossa ne râlez pas aidé pas
exponentielle mais on a tendance
foncière leur pressing et en économie
après les chiffres varient divers selon
et c'est dommage contre si l'espace est
certaine forme d'impunité des moments
dans l'année notamment les vacances nous
aimons harnais accomplissent des
vacances évidemment l'aspect
géographique
il est évident que si rôle que les
célébrations une chair mon cher et il y
à des modes opératoires également que
peuvent peut-être différent avec des
ports de des litres d'eau qui ont
tendance à apparaître et pas seulement
comment donc s'il va y avoir un panorama
général assez précis à celui-ci une
pause je pense que le plus important
encore pas même défi têtes s'intéresser
aux pourquoi ce sont plus de la sécurité
son fils menacé de tout et qui a été
développé ses vastes prochaine on sait
ce que l'homme a déjà parlé à une équipe
de sucre est très longtemps des pourquoi
aujourd'hui il semble que le saumon sont
plus longs de sécurité prennent ne pas
se tromper sinon notamment l'eau
portable est stérile je n'aimais garde
après les plus à avoir ça peut communaux
vont avoir eu des anciens collègues sont
encore en service actuellement
il ya en matière de délinquance violente
gratuit m'appelle des raisons futiles
regardons par une cyber et là il ya eu
de la violence violence on perd mais pas
énorme
elle leur revanche bonne excuse internés
au niveau qualité dire que la violence
est plus violent dans cette errance que
la violence c'est évident vous avez tout
enfin c'est ce qu'on constate évidemment
quand on regarde vous avez raison c'est
des violences gratuites qui se terminent
parfois par des morts en vendée des
choses absolument affreuse pour pour des
broutilles qu'on va pour des idées des
choses qui ne devraient pas aller
évidemment jusque là et c'est vrai que
peut-être et vous le vaisselier aussi
l'information qui se focalise sur tel et
tel événement peut aussi renforcer ce
sentiment d'insécurité mais au fond si
on regarde l'histoire moi j'avais fait
des études là dessus dans les années 70
si je me souviens qu'il y avait il ya eu
la loi sécurité et liberté d'alain
peyrefitte en 75 par là parce que qu'ils
répondaient déjà un sentiment
d'insécurité sentiment de sécurité ça a
toujours existé il ya toujours eu ce
débat c'est des criminologues notamment
à ce que c'est de la vraie insécurité
est ce que c'est le sentiment c'est
d'ailleurs ces délires ce que dit le
ministre de la justice dit c'est pas de
la sécurité on feb à rien mais ces deux
sentiments
c'est aussi votre travail brio le
sentiment d'insécurité
il n'est forcément de fait un hippie par
deux faits et et quand on voit
effectivement que le président de la
république parle d'incivilité lorsque il
y à ce chauffeur de bus qui a été frappé
à mort lorsque les forces de l'ordre
n'ont pas forcément été soutenu dans des
moments
on avait envie de les sentir soutenu
lorsque des policiers nationaux ou
municipaux font un flag et sont heureux
et fier d'avoir fait un flag et qu'ils
apprennent qu'en fait le soir les gars
sont sortis que la prison est plus
peut-être l'école du crime que de
l'insertion et c'est quand on met tous
ces phénomènes les uns après les autres
effectivement il ya un fort sentiment
d'insécurité et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
valérie pécresse disait l'autre jour à
sa rentrée politique
je pense qu'il faut un électrochoc
d'autorité c'est à dire que l'opinion
ressentent que ce ne soit pas
systématiquement un espèce de sentiment
de laisser aller et c est l site est
d'ailleurs l'exemple d'un pompier des
tempes le 14 juillet qu'ils éteignent un
feu de voiture qui s'est pris une balle
dans la jambe et qui disait alors on est
caillassée on est insulté personne ne
réagit donc après il ya les tirs de
mortier et puis après il ya les tirs
avec armes à feu donc tout ça concourt
au sentiment d'insécurité
le sort du vault de solitude où il fait
c'est ceux qui sont chargés du raté de
mustapha lahbiri là-dessus / / /
sentiments vous même vous êtes élue des
hauts fonds d'une ville où il ya parfois
on a parfois vue d'aider des effets
divers important d'abord sur le mot ans
sauvagement parce qu'il est prononcé
qu'on trouve en parler après avec entre
qu'on sait que c'était le mail en ce
moment sur ciment est ce que l on est
dans la sécurité ou est-ce que c'est
plus le sentiment
moi je considère que si déjà les gens
ont ce sentiment ce fait que après tout
déjà faut respecter ce sentiment ils
l'ont alors avant on avait un peu de
chiffres il se trouve maintenant dans le
si des images c'est compliqué
de commenter les chiffres déjà parce
qu'on y met un peu tout probablement
tout et n'importe quoi donc c'est
compliqué de trouver la justesse du
propos par rapport à des chiffres mais
ce qu'aujourd'hui on a des images qui
peut nier que les images ne sont pas
violents qui peut nier que ce que l'on
voit par définition c'est juste
insupportable c'est intolérable
donc oui par rapport à ce qu'on voit par
rapport à tous ces faits divers qui sont
maintenant film et ouais on peut être
qu'indigné simplement moi je suis pas je
ne suis pas dans dans l'exercice entre
guillemets de nids de la sociologie mis
dès l'année de la statistique mais j'ai
un vécu
j'ai un vécu et mon véhicule et celui
actuel devrait parler de trappes
effectivement que je suis depuis 16 ans
moi j'ai pas le sentiment d'insécurité
j'ai pas le sentiment d'être dans un an
dans un endroit violent par contre c'est
très paroxystique c'est vrai qu'il ya
des explosions de violences dans cette
ville probablement dans d'autres que je
ne connais mon mais moi j'y vis j'y vis
j'y vais dire très très près de
paisibles mans mais je vois bien les
comportements
moi ce que je vois changé au delà des on
parle d'incivilité alors quand on voit
les images de violence et puis des
incivilités la cdu cdu c'est hyper
violent c'est l'engagement c'est
dégueulasse c'est dégueulasse pour
prendre un nom tout simple c'est
sacrément dégueulasse c'est forcément
condamnable et et l'ensauvagement sur le
mont sauvagement par définition de pose
un problème parce que on peut parler de
ces sujets mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est
de trouver des solutions est un homme de
terrain par définition c'est de chercher
des solutions
ce mot à mon avis nous ne nous arrange
rien d'abord faudrait poser la question
à ceux qui le prononce ce monde moi je
sais pas ce qu'ils mettent derrière bas
est ce que ça veut dire qu'on est à la
limite de l'humanité ou de la bête
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent dire les gens
sont de réforme dans les gens sur
bestiaux les gens sont plus humains
est ce qu'on veut y mettre derrière
peut-être quand même des relents de
immigration ils viennent d'ailleurs ils
sont pas humains je sais pas ce qu'ils
veulent et c'est le sens dans leur
prochain parce que moi ça me gène le mot
sauvagement me gêne par contre
l'intolérance et nous grimpantes on se
supporte plus on parle de violence
gratuite il n'y a jamais rien de gratuit
pour une clope
on va te défoncer la gueule mais le mec
il a pris une clope c'est pas gratuit il
a gagné en club donc pour pour tout et
n'importe quoi aujourd'hui ça peut
dégénérer au mail frein à main au feu
rouge on va taper un mec parce qu'on a
parce qu'on nous a fait une queue de
poisson
il ya une espèce d'intolérance de
violence tout le monde est prêt à se
lâcher
voilà ce que je dis ce que je pense que
je constate aussi mais pour revient à ce
que je disais tout au début j'ai 50 ans
dans les quartiers j'ai 50 ans dans les
banlieues j'ai 50 ans pour avoir
travaillé un peu dans des territoires on
peut considérer que c'est à tort plus
violents qu'ailleurs en tous les cas
pour ceux qui y vivent
franchement ça n'a pas changé
si je vous racontais tout ce que j'ai
vécu dans ces quartiers est probablement
la police est partie mais moi je me
souviens de poniatowski qui faisait des
opérations coup de poing dans les années
soixante seize les opérations coup de
poing et ont ramassé tout ça en vrac on
disait qu'il y avait avec un coup de
menton où on allait dire qu'on a et
restaurer l'autorité
mais la violence n'était pas filmer la
violence n'était pas décrite comme
aujourd'hui la violence n'était pas
exacerbé il y avait par les réseaux
sociaux il ya parlé télé quand on loupe
franchement j'ai toujours vécu dans un
monde très violent je me demande à quel
point ils n'étaient pas plus violent
encore parce que c'est encore beaucoup
plus pauvres il y avait beaucoup plus de
difficultés et aujourd'hui par contre ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'on peut avoir le
sentiment il sage le comprend bah oui
parce qu'avec tous ces chiffres avec
toutes ces images et tout ce qu'on dit
qu'on répète en permanence sur les sur
les sur les télés sur les plateaux dans
les médias ouais on peut avoir que ce
sentiment d'insécurité mais moi pour
avoir grandi encore une fois en 50 ans
j'ai vu c'est violent deux bandes
rivales j'ai vu ces violences qu'on
appelle gratuite entre les mômes des
quartiers et les centres villes j'ai vu
dans les fêtes foraines des trucs
absolument terrifiante ci avait hésité à
éviter filmé à l'époque
aujourd'hui ça serait presque du petit
jeu sauf que ça s'est déplacé tard que
maintenant on va même sur les élus on va
même sur les livres on va
pas les gens qui arrivent dans un
instant ça va de plus en plus lointain
mais vous allez l'arrière sont les
raisons parmi eux le podiatre ski puis y
avait toujours des faits divers la
sphère patrick henry par exemple pour
nous tous le monde de réclamer la mort
de telles taxes faire c'est de l'anti à
113,19 avoue paris à versailles il ya eu
des rafales de sur des gens on appelait
ça la première bavure
j'ai vu de la violence dans les années
60 le 15 mai c'était impressionnant
il n'est pas fier mais il n'y avait pas
de chiffre ce n'est pas filmé en on
parlait pas alors aujourd'hui oui c'est
la météo
brandon beyrouth quel temps il fait
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on demande à
jean michel aulas heure justement sur un
temps long si on avait su on avait
statistiques il n'empêche qu'il faut le
traiter et avant m'étais un peu d'argent
sur l'éducatif maintenant on veut mettre
sous tout cet argent sur le répressif
moi je pense qu'il faut savoir écrit
libre et les choses parce qu'il ya des
choses à faire dans l'éducation mais
c'est un temps l'eau et dans le
répressif c'est un temps court and
charlène et jean baptiste vais peut-être
vous atterrissez sur les conséquences
politiques parce qu il ya eu une
déclaration d' emmanuel macron qui
parlons de la sécurité d'ila dit nous
connaissons le débat nous l'avons eu au
début des années 2000 et il a eu un
impact non négligeable sur la vie
politique et c'est vrai que si on se
rappelle la campagne présidentielle de
2002 elle s'est jouée sur la question de
la sécurité est elle explique en partie
parce qu'il est assez peu capable de
répondre à cette question le fait que
lionel jospin n'est pas été qualifié au
deuxième tour des présidentielles
c'est la preuve de ce que disait un peu
mustapha c'est à dire que c'est un débat
c'est un serpent de mer qui resurgit
très souvent moi j'ai le sentiment que
il y a deux choses dans ce qu'on évoque
l'ensauvagement d'abord en tant que
terme
je crois qu'il faut éviter les amalgames
et canton
au stigmatise ce terme d'ensauvagement
on y voit le terme de sauvages on
retrouve un discours racialiste où on a
le sentiment qu'on parle d'eux d'une
forme de rupture dans le vivre ensemble
et je ne crois pas que ce soit
finalement ce que le terme recouvre
complètement même si ce terme finalement
être complètement polysémique et il est
utilisé essentiellement pour des fins de
communication ou qu'il a même pas de
véritable nature
à part que c'est une francisation un peu
un parfum d'un vocable anglais mais
l'homme son engagement pendant longtemps
il a été réservé à l'extrême droite donc
aujourd'hui quand on a un ministre qui
nous parle dans sauvagement
on a le sentiment qu'on renoue avec les
vieux discours du père de marine le pen
et qu'on est donc en train de fracturer
complètement notre sentiment nous parler
de la république tout à l'heure notre
sentiment républicain notre unité
pourtant moi je crois que touche là
aussi à la halla halla aux pointes crête
de l'action publique et je rejoins ce
que disait mustapha c'est à dire que on
a beaucoup de mots si on dit incivilités
on a le sentiment que ça n'est pas
suffisant
si on dit ont sauvagement on a le
sentiment que c'est excessif
mais finalement ce qui nous manque ce
sont des actions et ça depuis les années
soixante dix comme vous le dites le
terme de sécurité la balance entre la
sécurité et la liberté c'est finalement
le la problématique même de la
démocratie et on en parle régulièrement
mais plutôt pour l'instrumentaliser
et au finish il n'y a jamais de réponse
politique à cette question de la
sécurité
on a essayé d'ailleurs de poser ce débat
même pendant le confinement sur la
question de la sécurité sanitaire et à
chaque fois il y avait de véritables
repli sur cette question donc moi je
crois que ce qui nous manque c'est un
véritable débat sur ce qu'est la
sécurité qu'elles sont aussi les
politiques qui doivent être menées sur
cette question est ce qu'il s'agit
plutôt de politique locale
est-ce qu'il s'agit plutôt de politique
nationale est ce que c'est une sécurité
face à quelle menace finalement une
sécurité sanitaire une sécurité lors des
regroupements et on retrouve là aussi
cette idée de la violence c'est à dire
que y'a tellement pas de réponses
politiques qui sont apportées que on
laisse libre cours à des discours
extraits
east extrémistes sécuritaire mais
extrémistes aussi de la division de
cette république dans ce fait de raviver
des groupuscules identitaires et donc
moi je crois que ce qui nous manque
c'est une vraie politique publique de la
sécurité qui soit penser autrement
qu'avec des indicateurs financiers
chaque année et un courage politique
dernière finalement je me suis
embrouillé interdire complètement
difficulté devant le chili est de
construire quelque chose de pérenne et
efficace
la sécurité c'est que beaucoup de gens
demandent mais en même temps le permet
pas son petit peu pour en découvrir et
combat on va quelque part pour aller
vers la sécurité tout de suite viande le
mot près le bo est prêt si on regarde et
de l'aîné débat qui n'est encore moins
c'est vrai et clôtures des caméras
la sécurité c'est quelque chose que l'on
demande mais c'est également des couples
quelque chose d'extrêmement la cuisine
je prends difficile d'arriver à faire la
part des choses en réalité mais c'est
réellement grenelle 2 cette idée qui met
ma foi choix des mots mais il ya aussi
peut-être en batiste il ya aussi un
jeune charlène le disais il ya aussi un
aria une arrière pensée politique quand
on emploie des mots comme ont
sauvagement qui sont en effet des
mouches de l'extrême droite c'est pour
dire regardez nous aussi on se préoccupe
de la sécurité puisque c'est un des
points qui sera probablement un des
points sensibles de des prochaines
campagnes électorales
derrière tout ça c'est vrai qu'il ya
toujours eu un discours politique
on entend d'ailleurs xavier bertrand se
scandaliser m'enfin il a été au
gouvernement il ya eu des faits divers
vous les aviez dupont dupond moretti le
retour de rappeler que quand il était au
gouvernement il y avait aussi des faits
divers qui avait choqué l'opinion
donc on est vraiment dans six dans une
question posture non là et qui consiste
à vouloir pénétrer en débattront sur le
sujet il ya un discours sémantique qui
se fait mérité le sujet c'est cette
espèce de collusion du moins peu
médiatique et politique d'un type qui se
jouent entre eux gérald darmanin des
médias gérald un moment peut-être
tempéré à gloire occupé le devant de la
scène médiatique et pour être écouté
c'est là que les choses sont en crise il
faut être excessif employer de termes
qui sont polis qui font le buzz
s'il avait employé une arme ou objet
d'adapter qu'il avait des bas de
contention la sécurité
toutes ces discussions qu'on a
aujourd'hui dès qu'on voit partout dans
les médias les râles darmanin on le sait
est un ancien l'épaule de sarkozy qui
partait ce discours sécuritaire pour
exister à paraître après les faits son
jeu et puis il le réussit bien puisque
tu m'en parlera aux abris ou voulaient
intervenir
je voulais rajouter un petit mot en
disant que
ce phénomène de sécurité ou d'insécurité
la source c'est l'éducation l'école et
c'est vrai que voilà voilà les souris
dansent et des actions pour les
associations et juste juste concernant
l'école justement il faut considérer
aussi tous ces jeunes issus de
l'immigration qui malheureusement sont
un peu sortis des radars de l'éducation
nationale parce que les parents sont
tentés de les mettre sur des voies
associative pour les sortir de l'école
de la république
et puis il ya aussi la période qu'ovide
qui a laissé ce flou vous pouvez aller à
l'école mais si vous considérez que etc
c'est vous vous ne vous n'allez pas à
l'école et c est en fait il y avait
beaucoup de flottement autour de l'école
qui doit rester vraiment la pierre
angulaire est nous avez raison il ya
beaucoup d'élus d'ailleurs pris 10 on
est en train de payer des conséquences
ducobu d'un et c'est possible que ça
joue alors puisque puisque vous preniez
la parole on n'a pas ce qu'en son
confinement gens me patrice un
confinement pour une personne pour un
couple qui habite dans une grande maison
avec jardin c'est le même film en te léo
lagrange à 8 dans un appart dans un f3
il fallait bien sortir pas de masse
n'est pas une chose parce que le grade
simplement si je peux rire est un mot
sur ce qui a été dit et je souscris
pleinement à ce qu'elle était au
contraire alors clairement faut pas être
naïf il ya de l'intolérance tous les
niveaux il ya de la brutalité il ya de
l'agressivité tout ça
on peut on peut le dire sans sans
sourciller simplement quand j'entends il
faut qu'on ait un débat serein il faut
que d'abord il est loin d'être serein
peut-être commencer par là mais je
considère que les solutions les crânes
et massa fait quarante ans qu'on nous
propose des choses c'est juste que s'il
faut qu'on ait un débat c'est par sur
les solutions à apporter c est ce qu on
les met en place ou pas il ya cette
obsession sécuritaire ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent parce qu'on considère que
l'éducatif
ça coûte beaucoup d'argent et ça ne
produit rien moi je considère que le
meilleur investissement reste une
question restera pour une raison très
simple c'est qu'on va venir à faire
beaucoup d'investissements sur le sur
l'éducatif
on le fera beaucoup plus et on
continuera à payer très cher pour le
côté sécurité a donc c'est même pas un
bon calcul
je continue à dire que l'éducatif c'est
la voie principale la voie royale
mais c'est sur du long terme le problème
c'est que les politiques je m'inclus
maintenant sont sur du court terme
on est sur le sujet pardonnez moi mais
j'ai vécu ça tout le temps va parler de
cette année sur le clientélisme les
imaginer les clients par définition qui
n'est pas du clientélisme on parle par
des clients mais les clients s'engouffre
on explique que tout va être gratuit on
va expliquer que tout est facile on va
expliquer mais à un moment donné
l'autorité l'autorité n'est pas simple
n'est pas un mot tabou qu'on soit de
droite qu'on soit de gauche
moi j'ai j'ai présidé du bonheur de
présider un club de foot a tramp vous
détendant pendant 14 ans par le maître
mot c'est est par définition rester sur
respecter l'autorité et la comprennent
autorités c'est simplement qu'elle est
plutôt je pense bien expliquée par
définition c'est sur des cas concrets on
passe par le sport ce qui est un vecteur
intéressant mais on peut le transmettre
à bien à bien d'autres sujets donc oui
il faut rester sur ce sujet là il ya 40
ans il y avait des méthodes qui avaient
été entreprises avec des éducateurs de
rue des éducateurs dans les quartiers
avec des maisons de quartier tout ça ça
a donné le sentiment que ça servait à
rien bah oui ça produisait rien au
quotidien ça ne produisait rien enlever
des éducateurs fumée s'est
éventuellement même un joint et tient
bon mais on disait faut arrêter il
jouait il joue au foot avec un monde
sont toutes arrêtées
le problème c'est que quand on investit
pourrait demander aux au plan borloo
d'investir sur ce sujet
c'est sur du long terme ou à long terme
alors quand on prend des décisions
politiques c'est souvent la prochaine
élection
quand on prend une décision politique
même au sommet ça reste la prochaine
élection simplement pendant ce temps là
c'est juste le pays qui en pâtit donc
les solutions les connaît il ya plein de
gens qui sont des spécialistes qui
travaillent sur ce sujet pharma citoyens
vous l'avez évoqué ouais moi je
travaille beaucoup sur la le mémorielle
je travaille beaucoup sur les choses
très concrètes et je vais chercher nos
enfants très tôt on a un peu tendance à
parler de l'ensauvagement où les
sauvageons donc on va chercher nos ados
dans les semaines non non c'est moi je
bosse je bosse sur les cm2 s'est massé
vraiment mon axe prioritaire c'est quoi
c'est tout on travaille sur la
citoyenneté qui est impavide amont mais
que mépris prêt à l'ajustement attendons
puisque vous parlez de la citoyenneté il
ya quand même dans ces agressions 233
mère je crois parce qu'on a fait les
comptes sains qui ont été agressés
depuis le début de l'année les
frontières pouces il ya des freins est
ce que est ce que vous en tant qu'élus
nous santé parfois ce rapport de
violence de la répression que les
frontières tombent et c'est vrai qu'un
élu qui était vu comme l'incarnation de
la république en toute simplicité et
et voilà aujourd'hui en fait on se dit
peu importe quoi ou c'est vrai que vous
disiez patrick 233 ses 133 1
il est peut-être un chaque jour donc
c'est quand même et on l'a aussi à des
images qui sont jean michel serres reste
mans il ya quand même attaques des élus
attaques des policiers ou des pompiers
on a senti le sens du mot quand même qui
a une perte de l'autorité enfin en tout
cas que l'autorité n'est plus respectée
en tant que tel est ce que c'est ce que
c'est exact ou pas sa meilleure année
que les policiers étaient partiellement
les policiers les pompiers ou les avait
cité les appartements sociaux médicaux
ou paramédicaux qui prévient que dans
certains endroits des prix les postiers
adn mais bien sûr les représentants de
l'état
mon premier rang policiers gendarmes et
pompiers
on le pleure et agressivement carrément
ça fait quelques années c'est de plus en
plus avec un paramètre qui est assez
nouveau qui est inquiétant c'est que
qu'on en prenne autant de ces agressions
sur les d sur les toits des policiers
ont souvent pressé souvent sur des rues
grèce aurait un déclencheur pour ce
déclencheur était souvent d'ailleurs une
intervention de police
aujourd'hui on se rend compte de plus en
plus que la plus besoin des bons
déclencheurs et que le quai tapant vont
cette fois nous leur amenons expression
peu le dernier jeu à laval pour le bon
dieu et que attirer les complaire dans
des pôles tiers du salaire est super
réel qui m'arrive
sunu parenthèse digressions diversiterre
sous dont il a quelque peu des deux les
chefs depuis kong 7 commissaire
divisionnaire qui était la direction
centrale des renseignements généraux
échelle de gravité alors 2 1 dans lequel
ces sinistres sur ben non seulement
généraux et que eux mais qu'ils avaient
lieu à partir du grossissement de
délectables en arriver à un point de non
retour après cet échec c'est que
précisément le pire à balles réelles au
représentant de l'état à l'aveuglette
mart a constitué et la nouvelle marche
et c'est avec cette version la tienne
est tout simplement la soumission la
rébellion
la génération merci comment son arrivée
est de mise en pot de l'amitié encore la
vision qu aucune recharge des nappes
audrey envieuse sa part au corps mène
alors que vous entendez dans la lys en
place une institution
on est réellement et jean va dire moi je
vais vous poser vous êtes des
enseignants vous êtes des jeunes
enseignants pas vous êtes jeune vous
avez des étudiants face à vous qui
parfois ne peuvent pour m avoir votre
art et c est ce que là aussi vous vous
constatez par rapport au moment où vous
avez fait vos études peut-être une sorte
de crise de l'autorité ou est-ce que ça
chagrine pas encore l'université h
moi je crois que à l'échelle
accepter les choses sont un petit peu
moins visible parce qu'on a des jeunes
de 18 ans qui on passe aux carrières qui
veulent passer une carrière de tourisme
le roi sont fondés en droit ou parce
qu'on y va travailler à battre donc on a
géré guidon pour demander des choses se
passent plutôt bien on est assez
satisfait mais c'est vrai que si on
observe ce à peu près 10 ans cède
j'aimerais que c'est vrai que j'ai le
sentiment que malgré tout les plus
difficile d'avoir de l'autorité oui mais
je crois que vous posez la question dans
trois continents vous avez un
gouvernement at-il voyage interrogés les
lui aussi dit la même chose
c'est un phénomène qu'il général il
vient de l'autorité quand il ya des
valeurs pas autorité lorsqu'on devant le
raconte moi en angleterre alors
parfaitement à la bombe ont fait
autorité parce que la décision l'ordre
de voir qu'on impose
et puis sur quelque chose de tout et je
crois que cette baisse d'autorité elle
fait une crise des valeurs qui en fait
en brasse occupe la société puisque la
liberté est un paroxysme hôtel que
chacun a le sentiment que ce qui est
juste c'est vont-ils droits sociaux
c'est sa passion bon moment ces cas
précis et comme il n'y a donc finalement
c'était spectre à destination de liberté
où chacun croit qu'il n'a plus à se
loger que obéir
finalement c'est renoncer à la liberté
les droitiers à la république et le
problème est là le problème on est là et
donc on a si vous venez d autorité qui
sont toujours institut qui fait un
travail et qui ont l'impression aux
finalement cédé aujourd'hui qu'avant
mais le problème et moi j'ai des raisons
d'être pessimistes tient au fait qu'il
n'y a plus de valeur et je ne crois pas
que nous allons vers un monde où les
valeurs des dents se rencontrent je
souscris totalement à ce qui a été dit
jusqu'à présent je me demande jusqu'à
quel point il n'y a pas un conte forme
de mouvement historique de l'autorité
c'est à dire que on a connu un
autoritarisme très grand nous et
beaucoup de jeunes démocraties de
l'europe dans la fin du 19e et on s'est
révoltés contre l'autorité parce qu'elle
apparaissait unique et illégitime donc
gérer qu'on est on a vécu un vingtième
siècle de la légitimité qui est
paroxystique avec la sphère filles ont
finalement on commence avec le triptyque
des lois de moralité de moralisation de
transparence de valeur absolue delà de
la probité qui est érigé en gouverne en
valeur clé de la gouvernance
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on attend du
gouvernement qu'il soit propre qui soit
transparent et qu'il soit moral donc on
est revenu un peu la leyre première des
prince de machiavel avec cette idée
qu'on peut faire dans un gouvernant un
homme qu'à partir du moment où il est un
homme bien lui même donc on revient à
cette valeur de la moralité
mais finalement j'ai le sentiment qu'en
revenant vers cette valeur de la
moralité on a complètement dissous le
paradigme même de l'autorité est donc je
me demande si le 21e siècle
olivier qui est vain la la la prochaine
étape de notre ère républicaine n'est
pas celle de l'autorité retrouver c'est
à dire qu'à partir du moment où on a
travaillé maintenant sur cette probité
sur les fondements mêmes de la
gouvernance est ce que maintenant il ne
serait pas temps de retrouver la dame
tout simplement l'édiction d'une norme
qui ne changent pas on a eu beaucoup de
souffrance avec ce confinement avec
cette crise sanitaire qui ont été bien à
des changements de cap qui on a été lié
à un manque de courage politique qui ont
fait qu'on ne comprenait plus les
orientations donc moi je me demande
jusqu'à quel point la population
finalement n'aspire pas à un courage de
l'autorité qui viennent maintenant de ce
prince que nous aurions choisi plus
propre et plus morale alors sous réserve
évidemment de trouver ce prince
transparent mais peut-être qu'en tout
cas il arrivera un jour je l'espère
c'est encore le brevet dans ciel alors
qu'il se trouvait
[Musique]
gouvernement et peuple gouvernance
associé à savon il ya une forme très
sévère de être seul c'est quelque chose
qui a joué pour s'appeler au nombre des
heures parce qu'on a évoqué tout à
l'heure des questions
une chose qui doit s'en présentait
justement le côté et qu'il faudrait des
allégations traditionnels que la
connaissons une éducation à la
frustration génération dont ils n'ont
pas été habitués à la frustration et qui
à leur tour
on nous a parlé de l'enfant roi
aujourd'hui l'enfant n'est plus l'enfant
mais est toujours le roi et il n'a
absolument pas été et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on refuse qu'on abat verbe
pour le dialogue n'a la violence on
remplaçait dialogue l'histoire a la
belle vie là ce sont des points d'arles
et comme je n'ai jamais très frustré je
veux ma cinar et le sucré à tuer tout ça
c est pour moi absolument obligatoire
mais c'est évidemment de ne pas revenir
sur le service militaire
mais bon c'est à moi que vous ayez un
mois j'étais là dessus réveillon
en maternelle une maîtresse me raconter
qu'un jour elle demande à un enfant quel
est ton brève
alors l'enfant dit la liberté qu'une
règle on aurait plus de règles alors la
maîtresse les prend au mot et dix bombes
alors on va vivre une classe où il n'y
aura plus de règles et donc qu'ils ont
commencé à faire et c est en fin de
matinée on en maîtresse on remet les
règles on a tous commenté maintenant
tout ce qu'on voit on est au courant du
phénomène
on a analysé les causes on les a
entendus avec des expliqué faut agir
peut-être toutes les autres tout ce que
j'ai entendu et merveilleusement bien ça
explique qu'elles m'ont bien les choses
problème il faut maintenant qu'on parle
des solutions et qu'on les mette en
place moi aussi j'ai une petite anecdote
qui était souvent souvent que j'ai
souvent entendu quand les certaines
personnes avaient eu affaire à la police
quand un moment donné ça chauffe est un
peu en général le mec disait retire-t-on
costard et on va se s'affronter d'homme
à homme
oui bon aujourd'hui on attend pas qu'il
enlève sans costa non c'est vrai donc
c'est ça qui fait que ça aurait pu
changer cercle auquel vous égarer ses de
gauche a osé gaffe c'est elle et lui dit
que c'était là c'était plus un
représentant de l'ordre leader qu'il
avait plus que c'est déjà assez sage oui
oui je veux bien mais nous serrer
violence latente veillée des recettes
il y avait du reste le même c'est ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure pour moi c'est
cette notion de respect encore une fois
et de représentation de l'autorité moi
je bosse tous là dessus c'est encore une
fois la violence existe elle existera
malheureusement toujours faut il
travailler mais ces symboles là par
contre eux sont tombés on tape un flic
avec son uniforme avant lui demander de
se décide d'enlever son képi ou à un
maire d'enlever son écharpe c'était
demain mais c'était le début mais red
bull mais c'est un mec vienne frites et
le flic tu es un homme vienne street et
la maintenance et garton que ce stage de
taper un texte peut-être parce que tu as
ton coach des routes ont déjà fermé mais
encore une fois l'aviron existait elle
était filmée mais je pense que dans si
on regarde ce furent les siècles la
violence on baisse plutôt qu'elle ne
montrerait qu'on parle des solutions et
qu'on les mette en application et encore
une fois avec un équilibre répression
éducation pas de naïveté sur le sujet et
puis mais par contre ça prend du temps
l'on réagisse et toujours à faire mais
ça prend du temps on va clore le dossier
violence sur lequel on a beaucoup parlé
et puis maintenant on va aborder
quelques thèmes assez rapidement eux qui
sont des ptom plutôt politique
vous parliez du long terme ben vous
allez être contents il ya un haut
commissaire au plan c'est françois
bayrou
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai qu'on est dans
l'immédiateté on a le nez sur le guidon
on réagit un instant au changement il ya
un fait divers on change les lois etc
c'est vrai qu'on avait abandonné ce haut
commissariat au plan
est ce que le fait de deux voilà d'avoir
d'avoir un organisme qui pensent les dix
les 15 ans qui vont venir c'est à votre
avis plutôt une bonne chose
alors c'est vrai que le temps long on ne
réclament suffisamment 1
c'est vrai pour le voilà après sur la
nomination de françois bayrou à ce poste
là on peut se demander dans quelle va
être la différence par rapport à france
stratégie qui était la modernisation de
leurs yeux comme jerry hall du
commissariat au plan
et puis voilà et puis et puis point de
suspension kw et puis c'est bon c'est
pas votre ami politique mais pour le
coup moi j'aime bien ces notions de
plans c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné
c'est une manière de ceux de réfléchir
ensemble de leurs obligations du plan
comme disait de celui de ceux projetés
mais il ya eu d'autres plans sur lequel
on aurait pu travailler avant d'aller
rechercher bayrou sur le plan sur son
plan parce que les plans ils peuvent
être ou technique c'est dire qu'à un
moment donné on se dit tiens la france
vallée sur l'énergie nucléaire ou au
contraire sur la transition écologique
et ça c'est des plans à long terme pour
un peu donner une orientation
enfin moi techniquement franchement je
fais confiance au chef d'entreprise fait
confiance aux créatifs je fais confiance
à tous ces gens là oui mais sa position
n'est ce pas le même pas pas
spécialement besoin de planifier comme
on l'a connu dans les années 60 même si
c'est important qu'on ait un cap une
donnée par une part par un pays comme
par exemple la réindustrialisation des
choses comme ça moi je préfère les plans
sur lequel on travaille sur l'humain
justement le plan le plan borloo par
exemple était un plan oui on l'abandonné
et pourtant les notions dont on parle
aujourd'hui était dedans moi j'ai
participé à beaucoup de tables rondes
sur le plan borloo et avant le plan il y
en a eu d'autres avant et je crois que
tous ceux qui ont participé et on
regrette qu'elles étaient abordés
society c'est un plan comme le plan
nucléaire ou la france va être projeté
dans trente ans où la violence sera bien
évidemment beaucoup moins qu'elle n'ait
où on aura une éducation de nos enfants
qui seront beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
encadrée et c'est ça c'est des plans qui
m'intéresse celui là j'ai peur que ça
soit un bon plan pour lui
pour bayrou j'ai peur que ce soit un bon
plan
un bon plan un bon plan mais j'entends
politiquement parce qu'il va
bénévolement et je souscris au bénévolat
mais j'aime bien moi les plombs qui
emmène la nation sur des quasi sujet
philosophie qui est plus que technique
mais c'est des sujets philosophiques ses
caisses que qu'est ce que votre société
c'est ça l'idée c'est d'essayer de
définir ce que va être la france la
société l'europe dans 15 ans et que
c'est quand même assez pour des c 'est
blanca li na c'est ça le plan je salue
mme carven on peut rappeler un cessez de
gaulle en 46 le premier commissaire au
plan ces monnaies d'ailleurs très très
très de manière très très amusante on va
où de très significative
la plupart des gouverneurs au plan était
de très pro-européens ya bonne
évidemment mais la plupart très pro
européens est-ce que alors ya quand même
une question qui se pose c'est à dire
que en 46 l'état est très fort
aujourd'hui l'état n'a plus beaucoup de
moyens est ce que c est ce que c'est pas
un cache misère au fond alors d'abord il
faut aimer une première chose sur le
plan go vous avez un peu retracé
l'historique on dit très souvent dans
les médias ces derniers jo on renoue
avec le commissariat au plan et que
c'était quelque chose que nous avions
abandonné c'est une erreur le plan n'a
jamais été abandonné parce que tout
simplement tout état démocratique qui se
respecte depuis les années 50 dispose
auprès des ministères d'un organisme de
conseil alors on a là la direction des
affaires régionales auprès des
collectivités territoriales on
affrontera tegick et qui a changé de nom
aussi tous les dix ans auprès de l'état
qui sont des organismes de prospective
scientifique et justice à ce collectif
vient aider les ministères justement au
niveau des chiffres mais le plan tel
qu'on l'a conçu dans les années 50 était
avant tout un plan économique et un plan
de relance à la suite d'une guerre
justement moi je trouve que le fait que
nous renouions avec ce
champ lexical est pas inintéressant
parce que emmanuel macron a joué
beaucoup avec le champ lexical de la
guerre avec la guerre contre le virus et
cetera nous savons que nous vivons une
crise économique y est sans précédent et
donc je pense que le plan arrive ici au
bon moment c'est à dire que c'est avant
tout un plan économique finalement un
plan de rétablissement de l'état il vous
parliez de perte d'autorité de l'état
peut-être que justement ce plan rétablir
en tout cas le nu ce d'un ministère
enfin un commissariat qui soit
complètement attitré au plan de lui
redonner un petit peu de l'ampleur
politique c'est le moment de renouer
avec justement le plan économique de
relance et de reconstruction qui est à
l'origine même du plan ensuite redire
aussi un mot c'est que dans les années
50 le plan a ensuite évolué vers un plan
qu'on qualifiait de plan état région qui
était le moment justement du dialogue
local dans lequel les régions ont
d'ailleurs connu les leurs plus grandes
années parce que c'est là qu'elles ont
beaucoup impulser les politiques
publiques donc à l'heure où la
population réclament de plus en plus de
pouvoir aux localités
peut-être que le plan va permettre aussi
de redonner du pouvoir aux territoires
et donc je crois que c'est le bon moment
signe d'une bonne réponse politique à
plein d'égards pour relancer notre pays
et peut-être pour leurs pensées au
niveau de sa gouvernance territoriale
très bien autre sujet parce qu'il faut
qu'on aille très vite du der est à peine
quatre minutes
il ya une partielle 1 dans la rosée de
circonscription des yvelines
je crois qu'il ya déjà onze candidats à
la suite de la nomination de nadia haye
comme ministre de la ville et qui
n'avait pas de suppléant où il y avait
un suppléant qui était poursuivi par la
justice
en tout cas il ya un homme dont on
aurait pu penser qu'il allait se
présenter
qui a été le député de cette
circonscription c'est benoît hamon à
votre avis pour payer c'était une chance
inouïe pour lui de revenir sur le devant
de la scène politique ou dans la scène
politique en tout cas pourquoi il va pas
très bien très vite moi j'aime moi j'ai
le sentiment comme ça rapidement qu'il a
pendant que se planter encore une fois
s'est planté était des plus disent que
les sondages le donnaient en tête en ce
moment ensuite aux régionales ensuite
aux présidentielles peut-être que le
suffrage unis
aircelle c'est pas pour lui donc c'est
peut-être filezilla les jetons
deuxièmement il ya peut-être une autre
une autre idée c'est qu'il a lancé un
mouvement qui est quand même génération
l'aise il a ses lieutenants maintenant
qu'ils sont par exemple et probablement
qu'il a plutôt envie de laisser voir
comment ces idées sont partis peu évolué
avec d'autres moi j'ai plus l'impression
qu'il a à la fois les jetons et en même
temps peut-être que ces idées peuvent
être propagée par d'autres il va suivre
ça de loin
josé main il n'y avait pas intérêt à y
aller votre vie mais se prépare
peut-être pour les présidentielles oui
pour sa palette deux fois autre débat
qui va vous faire plaisir estrosi qui
dit bon c'est pas la peine qu'on ait un
candidat de droite il ya macro j'aime
bien christian estrosi et voilà je pense
que à nouveau c'est un peu un coup de
com mais je pense que c'est un peu tôt
pour faire sa déclaration d'amour
à maquereau je pense qu'avant il y à
2020 la crise 2021 les scrutins
départementaux et régionaux et après on
pourra peut-être commencer à parler
c'est le jugement des présidentielles et
des engagements on pensait que ça serait
partial qui auraient des persiennes une
partielle enfin pourrait s'orienter
parce qu'il ya beaucoup pendant jeudi
par s'y est mal pris je pense qu'on
plonge vers une primaire alors il ya
beaucoup de gens ce que ç'a porté chance
à des infos mais non mais c'est en fait
les primaires ont été très bien menée
mais je trouve que ça s'est très bien
passé c'est juste le problème du
candidat est ce qui s'est passé après
mais là la première recoller les
morceaux et c'est vraiment des goûts on
n'a pas cet afflux façon macro n'est ni
de gauche ni de gauche il l'a dit à sa
façon il est temps de rejoindre la
droite
en un mot une polémique avec un dessin
qui est paru dans valeurs actuelles sur
la députée danielle bonneau qui a été
représentée en esclaves et à juste titre
a pu choquer et et beaucoup de beaucoup
de gens se sont se sont prononcés contre
cette caricature mais peut-être à me
permettre de vous interroger le dessus
en même temps dit faut soutenir charles
ix ème nous qui fait des caricatures wes
kewes que la limite qu'est-ce qui est
caricaturable qu'est ce qui ne l'est pas
est ce que c'est le droit qui doit dire
ça et je vous demande de répondre
rapidement pardon 23/10 dit peu de
choses si finalement on a le droit
européen des droits de l'homme qui nous
dit que tout dépend du discours quand on
est dans un discours sarcastique quand
on est dans quelque chose d'humoristique
qui vient volontairement provoqué ou
choquer la liberté d'expression ne
connaît normalement pas de limite donc
c'est à dire que vous pouvez tout à fait
choqué même religieusement même
politiquement même au niveau d'un
discours qui pourrait apparaître raciale
si vous me faite sur le ton de l'humour
alors tout dépend justement de ce qu'on
peut considérer comme étant le tout de
valeurs actuelles charlie hebdo est
connu pour son côté provocant et pour
justement le fait de rechercher un
humour noir valeurs actuelles s'illustre
ici
dans un discours qui est un peu nouveau
par rapport à ce qu'il portait et le
risque aussi c'est de politiser ce débat
puisque justement valeur actuelle est
plutôt connu pour des positions
politiques donc le risque d'utiliser le
ton char me quand on met pas charlie
c'est d'être sanctionné par la loi
qu'est ce que du coup cette limite de
l'humour elle risque d'être franchi
merci beaucoup malheureusement voilà le
temps ça passe vite perdriau va merci à
julie baup à la ba oui merci beaucoup
jean-michel chausseur merci beaucoup
me jean baptiste du club merci j'avais
dû clair merci beaucoup et peu à la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de paf
[Musique]